a crackdown on press freedom this is a
report by the Committee to Protect
Journalists accusing China of preventing
journalists in Hong Kong and Taiwan from
reporting freely it details an
increasingly constrained media
environment in Hong Kong where
pro-beijing outlets outnumber the
independent ones pro-beijing groups are
also accused of scaring off companies
from advertising with independent
outlets who can be critical of China the
report says that they've been repeated
and unprovoked police attacks on
journalists in Hong Kong have been
covering the protests the Committee to
Protect Journalists says these are the
effects of China's rising influence on a
region that once had Free Press
yes Sarah Clark in Hong Kong was
obviously reported right throughout this
whole process of protests in Hong Kong
and has been looking at the report today
take us through some of the conclusions
of it Sarah
well as you mentioned Kamala this is
looking at the the changing media
landscape in Hong Kong
due to the increasing Chinese influence
on those media outlets and the overall
conclusion is that it's not a positive
situation for the media here it says
China's diminishing inhibitions to
intervene in Hong Kong's affairs has had
unfortunate consequences for journalists
it said the cause of Hong Kong's more
restrictive environment is the
increasing control of the large media
companies which have come under mainland
control or ownership or influence it
says the media outlets with the Chinese
a slant they tend to get heavier
investments or bigger greater income
incoming funds from the Chinese
companies and it says the alternate so
it pays to be proton oh now it talks
about how that's translated to greater
pressure on the independent media
outlets which they said are diminishing
as a result simply because they're being
underfunded they say those who criticize
or dare to question our China are being
starved of any funding income from
advertising or other finances and it
says the independent media who
questioned as mentioned the Chinese
inputs the there are some on the online
stance or the online platform for the
independent operators it's certainly
thriving but it still says that the
number of outlets the independent media
or journalists are diminishing as a
result now also a particular focus in
its report is looking at the violent
attacks that have been increasing in the
last six or so months certainly the last
twelve months and that's been inflicted
by the police and sometimes pro-china
our supporters now we spoke to the
co-author of this report at Steven
Butler and this is what he had to say
with regards to the increasing number of
attacks on journalists in Hong Kong it's
put the media up on the front line
against
and we've seen many instances of police
is doing really gratuitous attacks on
journalists journalist who is standing
at the side who were tear gassed or hit
with pepper spray or in the case of one
journalist who was hit by you know a
live rubber bullet and boster eyes one
eye sight in one eye and there's no
justice for any of these none of these
cases are being investigated so far as
we know and the police are not being
held to account and so I think this has
led to an increasing divide as for the
protest movement itself Sarah what sort
of stated that in now are things winding
down a bit
listen Li Kumar they're continuing but
the number of rallies are smaller and
the number of people attending those
rallies are also declining we had some
small confrontations on the weekend at
some of those rallies and that was
between police some protesters as well
as journalists and this week there is a
general strike called for between
Tuesday and Thursday now there was a
general strike last week but it actually
didn't eventuates were yet to see what
will come of this week's strike and I
should also say the Hong Kong the
government here has taken out a number
of ads in newspapers in Australia Europe
and the United States and it says that
Hong Kong is soldiering on it's trying
to basically kind of reassure our
countries around the world that Hong
Kong is still a good place to invest it
notes that Hong Kong is a free and open
society and it says that the Hong Kong
government still respects the one
country two systems policy now Hong
Kong's chief executive Carrie Lam is
currently in Beijing she set to meet Xi
Jinping this afternoon this morning she
met two Premier Li who noted Hong Kong's
unfortunate economic situation he said
that China has noted that Hong Kong is
not out of hot he's noted that Hong Kong
is not out of its financial dilemmas yet
but it says the economies are currently
facing unprecedented and challenging
times but we expect Carrie Lam to update
that all of us tomorrow which is Tuesday
when she does potentially our briefing
on that visit to Beijing thank you for
that Sarah Clark in Hong Kong